posters are off in the first way to get
moviegoers excited for the next big
release the trick for a studios
marketing team is to tease something
cool about their upcoming movies without
giving away too much considering that a
poster is just one picture you would
think that wouldn't be too difficult but
sometimes designers get a little too
excited and present an image that
somehow manages to reveal way too much
maybe they thought audiences wouldn't
notice or wouldn't care but they can't
deny that these posters ruined the
entire movie in case the title of this
video didn't tip you off warning massive
movie spoilers ahead prometheus there's
a lot about Prometheus that audiences
might find confusing and that's beyond
Michael Fassbender's unnerving portrayal
of an Android named David character
motivations are murky the setting is
sometimes obscure and the whole thing is
supposed to be a prequel to alien there
are plenty of quiet moments which are
not common in a modern sci-fi movie but
eventually prometheus gets around to
what we all go to the movies to see
big-budget CGI explosions the film's
action Peaks went to gleaming futuristic
spaceships crash into each other while
humans watch from below you might
recognize this climactic i popping scene
from the poster as the explosion is the
key image split in night Shyamalan's
unbreakable stars Bruce Willis as a
Philadelphia man named David Dunn who
comes to realize that he's nearly
invincible while crossing paths with his
villainous opposite the fragile boned
Elijah price aka mr. glass when it was
released in 2000 Willis announced that
the film was part of a planned trilogy
but a sequel never materialized until it
did when nobody was looking in 2017
Shyamalan had his biggest hit in years
with the psychological thriller split
starring James McAvoy as a disturbed man
with 24 separate personalities who
kidnaps a trio of teenage girls at the
end he escapes and viewers learn more
details about the man on the loose via a
news report playing on a TV in a diner
buzzer
mr. lash split was set in the same
universe as unbreakable all along
who knew fans who remembered both
posters that's who the two images share
a virtually identical breaking glass
pattern the average moviegoer might have
missed it but for Shyamalan diehards the
split poster gave away its big reveal
ahead of time Avengers infinity war in
the box office behemoth Avengers
infinity war intergalactic villain
Thanos completes his savage quest for
the Infinity stones he uses them to
instantaneously wipe out half of all
life in the universe including many of
the superheroes assembled by the
Avengers to stop him for a studio to
kill off so many beloved moneymakers
always comes as something of a surprise
even if most of them will presumably
come back to life in the sequel but if
you were a Japanese fluent fan who saw
the Japanese poster you had those
sacrifices spoiled by the tagline which
translates to Avengers totally
annihilated I don't want to go don't
want to go please
Deadpool to both the content and
marketing of the Deadpool films are rife
with sarcasm self-awareness and
self-deprecation that silliness was on
full display in the Deadpool Tube poster
which looks like a 60s Italian spy movie
crossed with Smokey and the Bandit such
a piece of promotional art would have to
include the funniest smarmy and most
sarcastic tagline possible well the
Deadpool team could have just spoiled
their own movie they instead decided to
reveal the ending of another movie set
in Fox's x-men universe
Logan which was released a year before
Deadpool - marked the last time Hugh
Jackman would lead a movie as the
Wolverine that fact was made quite clear
by the Deadpool 2 poster which featured
the tagline from the studio that killed
Wolverine carry the 1976 teen horror
classic Carey is about a teenage girl
kept sheltered away from the world by
her domineering and deeply troubled
mother why because Gary can do powerful
things with her telekinetic mind
insecure and socially awkward she's
bullied by the other kids at school and
it all comes to a head at the prom Mean
Girl Norma gets Carrie elected prom
queen as a joke Carrie thinks she's
finally won over her horrible classmates
until they soak her with a bucket of
pig's blood that sets off Carrie who
uses the full extent of her mental
powers to kill pretty much everyone
present it's the climax of the film and
it's revealed on the poster happy prom
queen Carrie juxtaposed next to Angry
blood-drenched Carrie
[Music]